i think it would be cool to just go
around town and actually get a lay of
the land
here in like downtown l.a see what it's
really like out there
i don't really care about it are you
taking any precautions no
no no no no my immune system is good
enough i don't care
[Music]
when we went out to texas the day we
landed we found out there was someone
confirmed with the chronovirus they went
to a mall
in san antonio where we were filming for
nico jake clinton myself i brought four
n95 masks
jake really roasted me and made fun of
me and made me feel bad and i almost
took it off
and then we fly back new alarm bells
ringing tonight on the coronavirus
outbreak in this country
officials there cautioning people about
how they should interact with others
going forward
i was right now all this gear is from
san antonio you know hey
just yeah this feels good i can finally
fist bump you the best fist bump
obviously like you know everyone's
practicing the the elbow thing
because you want to avoid the hands and
the wrists you know because the germs
can travel down your wrists a little bit
you know what's better the cross guard
yeah the chicken wings
look at this our faces are right in
front of each other if you were to
sneeze
i'm i'm dead yeah put out your knees
knees worked
these words
how are you matt maintains a good six
feet from each other that is something
that they say right that you have to
maintain a distance like six feet
you guys are not six feet away from each
other yeah you gotta keep the face six
feet bro
good to see you good to see you i go to
the grocery store empty
just freaking empty you could hear the
wind blowing through so i was like okay
i went to ralph's same situation just a
bunch of people
full of carts all the way around the
store no chicken
there was meatloaf there was a lot of
meatloaf it's like guys we have all this
meatloaf over here it's like no i'd
rather starve to death
than eat the meatloaf the toilet paper
was the first thing to go
it's like there are many ways to wipe
your butt if you're quarantined
at home you just take a shower after you
take a dump
i think there's a line between panic and
precaution
we hear a lot in the news we hear a lot
you know over social media but i think
it would be cool to just go around town
and actually get a lay of the land
here in like downtown l.a one of the
most densely populated places in the
country
see what it's really like out there you
may be wondering
why we're in the office right now if
we're talking about all these
precautions we need to take
but we're at the point still where we
can at least get together make a plan
for things
it's very realistic that as of wednesday
everybody's going to be working from
home so we can be doing our part
to prevent a spread of this disease
there's a cap on the number of people
that could be in a building at one time
now at these
grocery stores so that means there's a
line to get into the grocery store looks
like they have
supplies though there's people coming
out with fully stocked cars the supplies
are here they just got
wiped out of the stores immediately
because of panic so this is the
precautionary uh measure against panic
so we're gonna go ahead to downtown now
to see what some of the stores are like
in the city we're really close to what's
called skid row here in l.a
we have food there's a supply line this
is a perfect example of it
you know la is a distribution hub for a
lot of america a lot of stuff comes in
through
long beach and it gets chipped out
everywhere so you can see that there's
stuff there's stuff everywhere
it's just a matter of getting it onto
the trucks and getting into the right
store and getting into the hands of
people in a safe manner
the only reason that we don't have the
supply is because uh other than men
everybody's getting a big big
corporations and small businesses like
us
we're not able to get any any product no
no eggs no beans no rice because of all
the big corporations taking advantage of
it so
small business like us we don't even
have toilet paper when we were one of
the first suppliers that we
that we had i mean we're buying
truckloads of toilet paper but
unfortunately we cannot
find it well i mean it's all about
self-control you know i mean i mean
there's product out there this product
is just that
we humans make this chaos and even the
prices are going up
they're going crazy yeah i mean toilet
paper we set up like
uh we bought a pallet last week for
twenty dollars we bought it for twenty
dollars
when we were buying it for like nine
eight dollars it's either we get it or
someone else get it so
more than anything i think it's more of
self-control you know because there
there is product out there just that we
are the ones making it more harder
to get yeah so this is the market
district it's right next to uh where we
live we're just talking about how you
know other places are closing down you
have to stand in a line to get into
smart and final mcdonald's
you can't go in the lobby and then
here's a bunch of stalls set up on the
sidewalks it's packed there's people
walking around it's not exactly the most
sanitary conditions
so people aren't necessarily taking out
the same level of seriousness yet
there's the other concern which is
important to talk about which is the
economic concern
you know it's like you take a week off
the work that's a week you're behind
your paychecks it's a week that you're
behind on your bills
it's not an easy thing i mean it's
something we have to consider at
corridor like
i want people to be safe but we also
need to make sure that work is getting
done
especially we're gonna be in a bit of an
economic downturn we need to make sure
we have our
cash flow coming in so that everybody
sells a job if you're out of a job right
now
apply for unemployment immediately it
takes a little while to go through you
get your job back in a few weeks great
no worries unemployment doesn't matter
but if you're going to be out of work
for a month or two get that unemployment
right now to make your ends meet until
this all passes you can get back into it
you can get unemployment if you're on a
1099 you can get unemployment for
temporary leaves also
this is the fashion district it's
basically where a lot of uh fabric comes
through the united states
once again coming in from overseas and
once again it's a lot quieter
than it used to be don't be fooled by
all the dazzling colors
there's a fifth to a tenth of the people
that are usually here um
the cdc has downgraded the virus from
airborne to just droplet
which means you actually have to come
into contact with fluid uh
to catch the virus now the important
caveat there is that that fluid can be
airborne in and of itself whenever you
sneeze or cough sure that's the whole
like the three foot radius bubble
aspect of it so if we're just out and
about it's not like you could breathe in
the virus
but if someone coughs on you you can
absolutely get it
it's about a 20-minute wait to get in so
far yeah about a 20-minute wait right
now
this is the world we've come to grocery
stores in the new nightclubs you wait to
get in
the bouncer only lets you in when
they're out of capacity and so you're
saying that all the attractive women can
go into the grocery store right away
right
starbucks has taken away all their
chairs so that you get your order to go
and
not hang out
it's like all these veggies all these
fruit
yeah they're looking pretty stocked huh
yeah they must have just restocked like
last night
there's something you need you should
absolutely get it if you get the chance
but like
don't get like a month's supply just get
a week's supply cuz i guarantee you
within a few hours this place is gonna
be super crowded with the lion this is
not going to last
i guess we have enough tortilla chips
i'm not gonna lie it's
it's a little spooky it's just a little
spooky it's gonna be shelves it's a
little weird
yeah how are you feeling are you worried
at all no no they just want less people
on their
street i drove down here at like 8 30 no
traffic
and usually i'm you know bumper to
bumper at that time on a monday
good luck man good luck man stay safe
yep
are you guys feeling about this whole
thing i don't really care about it
are you taking any precautions no no
absolutely not
my immune system is good enough i don't
care do you have family that could be
susceptible
no interesting okay and they're gone
no my dumpling this is the best poke
place in all of la
right here in the heart of a japanese
grocery store the best sushi burritos
poke wraps i'm gonna get some right now
it was kind of spooky is going on amazon
trying to get baby formula
that was all sold out that was like
that's why i started getting a little
worried
i feel like if i just like chill on
buying groceries until like the end of
this week
things will be restocked like i mean
this is a perfect example of what i was
talking about is like that is something
you need
and you're not going to hoard a bunch of
it you're just going to get what you
need the line is
crazy right now
there's definitely a storm brewing
literally and figuratively
i am feeling raindrops so yeah that's
what it looks like out in l.a right now
it's it's an interesting time
it's important to be taking this
seriously it's important not to panic go
crazy
hoard everything remember don't strain
the system the system will work
food will continue to be distributed
we've distributed food through world
wars
before this is okay we'll be fine if you
want to start stocking up on things do
it gradually do it slowly
don't go to the store and just clean
them out i want to give you guys a handy
tip here you may notice that stores are
sold out of hand sanitizer
sanitizing wipes sanitizing spray all
that kind of stuff all these modern
conveniences but you know what
it's very very easy to make your own
cleaning liquid all you do is put a
little bit of bleach
into a big thing of water basically
you'll dilute it one part bleach to
about 20 parts water
you can put in a spray bottle you can
put it in like a big tub and you can dip
rigs in it and wipe things with it that
little bit of bleach and water will
disinfect
surfaces it'll disinfect your phone
screens it's a great way to create your
own
disinfecting solution and bleach is very
easy to come by it is not sold out one
of the things we talked about in this
video is the economic impact of
stores closing down restaurants shutting
the doors people having to go on
unemployment things like that we also
want to make sure that we have the money
to pay our bills and keep everybody
employed especially if we're all gonna
be working from home for a couple weeks
here so
i want to thank squarespace for
sponsoring this video unfortunately jake
is still in texas he'll be back tomorrow
so i'm doing the squarespace address
today
what but you know what jake has done a
great job informing me and the fact they
have some award-winning templates it's a
very easy to use website and it has lots
of great features that make website
building
easy and accessible tell me more about
squarespace and you go so squarespace
allows you to purchase your own domains
it has web hosting it basically makes
the whole website building process
easy and approachable and it has a bunch
of extra features to let you take
your website beyond just a regular
website for example you have audioblocks
you can get some nice stock audio to put
into your podcast
you have email campaigns that you can
run you have multi-user contributions
you can have multiple people working on
the same site there's a whole bunch of
things that squarespace does to make
website building easy
and we've actually used squarespace for
our site building many times the
templates look awesome and honestly
all website building aside squarespace
has actually been a huge beneficial
force in the world
of online media they've sponsored a lot
of artists to make really cool things
and they really have never been too
intrusive so they've done a great job of
supporting the arts so to speak and with
that i want to thank them and if you
guys want to check out squarespace you
can head to squarespace.com
coral crew and you actually get 10 off
of a website domain
purchase so you can buy your own
blanketyblank.com
squarespace.com corridor crew there's
information in the description if you
would like to click on that and start
building your own website right now
thank you for watching everybody please
stay safe up there stay level-headed
mature respectful cautious
together you can get through this while
having a pandemic that causes a lot of
issues for our health system as well as
our senior citizens
it's not about whether or not you get
sick so whether or not the people who
are vulnerable get sick
we all want to do our part and keep
everyone safe one more thing
everybody in the office is going to
suggest one good movie for you to watch
while you're at home easy
knives out my favorite movie of 2019 i
just saw it for a second time over the
weekend it is so incredible it's so
intelligently written and directed
everything about knives out is is
amazing lighthouse
it's amazing your best bet is to go
through the entire friday the 13th
series that's
12 movies i just gave you and at least
three of them are good
at least three my girlfriend and i have
been going through the entire series of
mad men
probably get you through the entire
two-week quarantine next couple months
if it gets worse
hit up that disney plus ball animated
clone wars series i just finished all
the mighty ducks
i'm watching recess i'm watching doug
all that stuff is great
check out this show called kingdom it's
on netflix
really intense zombie uh series about
feudal korea season two just dropped
challenge soccer challenge soccer you
watch yelling soccer yeah
i don't know